[Music]
[Applause]
all right I mentioned that I got to see
the movie air on Monday there was a
screening down in New York uh Matt Damon
Ben Affleck Viola Davis they were there
in attendance and uh the movie is about
Sonny Vaccaro and Nike and the pursuit
of Michael Jordan and creating that
partnership that really rebelized
revolutionized the World of Sports and
and culture Matt Damon plays Sonny
Vaccaro Ben Affleck Jason Bateman Viola
Davis also in it Chris Tucker is got a
starring rule as well hits theaters on
April 5th as we bring in Sonny Vaccaro
how close did you come to losing Michael
Jordan at Nike
every day every day was a challenge I
was the stranger when I first met him I
never met him um George Rowling
introduced me and I knew George very
well at that time he was my best man at
our wedding but since that that first
day there was some sort of a connection
that I you can't explain people would
make you know they did this it was like
Karma or something I can't explain it to
you but every day from the first day on
for the next three and a half months in
pursuing him was a chore because the
idea for me was to help convince him to
believe in this young company that might
do something that they've never done
before
that was the chore and Michael was
Michael you know 21 22 years old he is
now you know 40 something but he had his
own mind his idea what he wanted to do
and he didn't want to go with Nike
that's for sure so it was my greatest
journey and you know I've had a few of
these things but the other things
basically in my life Dan I controlled
whether it was that first All-Star Game
whether it was paying the coaches it was
serious you know seriously my idea this
was an idea that was given to me the
opportunity by you know Phil Knight and
Rob Strasser and Peter Moore and
especially Robin and Phil they gave me
the okay I never thought in my wildest
dreams that I would ever be involved on
the professional side and recruiting a
player that was going to be the
signature of Nike forever
but I didn't know if it was more about
recruiting Michael's mom in the movie uh
played by Viola Davis or was it more
about recruiting Michael to Nike Michael
was always Michael but I knew that
family not specifically Mrs Jordan at
that time but family was what guided
Michael so after the first meeting I
knew that the only way to Michael's
heart was we got to convince his family
I didn't assume and I I don't want to
think anyone to say anything that I said
we're going to go from this I just said
I knew family was big in that short
period of time and Michael Jordan really
only listened to family and then mom who
does no question
did Nike make Michael did Michael make
Nike
let me just say this I have no idea what
history neither do you Mr Patrick but
without Michael Jordan he made
everything and he made you people in the
media talk about the goat the best
player and all that I'm not getting
involved with that crap because I
believe personally Senator the goat is
the guy who's the best player in the
generation you play so let's get past
the goat stuff okay let's get past
Michael with it the LeBron and you know
and this guy and that guy but what he
was the goat of for Nike start with Nike
but the rest of the world was marketing
what he did he opened up a billion
trillion dollar industry for people that
he never met and who are they the
athletes and particularly the minority
athletes of today's society he opened up
a venue that he could be a part
ownership in he's Sonny Vaccaro the
former Sports marketing executive he
signed Michael Jordan to that first
sneaker deal at Nike so you leave Nike
you go to Adidas do you have a chance to
sign LeBron because he wore Adidas in
high school I believe how did Adidas
screw that up that LeBron ended up going
to Nike
the LeBron story is quite different than
the Michael story I knew you know
LeBron's family including mom and all
his all the young you know Maverick when
they were 10th 11th grade in high school
that one was someone I when I made my
break it was like when I found Kobe for
Adidas in in 96 or 97 and Tracy the next
year after that that I did that pretty
good and I knew this kid was going to be
pretty good because the people in you
know his hometown they brought a film to
me but Adidas screwed up the way you did
this historically screws up okay they
should have had Michael Jordan this
conversation in 84. Michael would have
gone with them for 50 cents more for a
financial part of it they offered much
more on the surface until we screamed a
pot and said you're going to get a
percentage so LeBron LeBron was
ignorance Adidas made a horrible mistake
a horrible mistake they changed I
offered LeBron
you know a hundred million dollars 10
million dollars a year while he was
still in high school never signed
anything we didn't break any violations
I I met him and his family you know and
I said this is what it's going to be
and until that moment until the day of
the signing we were supposed to sign I
was given permission Dan in my lifetime
whoever I work for I never spent other
people's money without them giving me
the opportunity to spend other people's
money it wasn't like I was guaranteeing
it but Adidas told me that given the 10
million a year I go to this meeting and
you know in Malibu when LeBron flies out
and you know the team flies out we're
whining the diner I was in his home I
was back you know in you know in Ohio
with them I watched them grow up and all
that sort of stuff
we open up the contract
it wasn't 100 million they had
incentives in there oh well my first
life my first thing was you know you're
giving a guy 100 million dollars you're
worried about incentives you're hope
you're hoping he can play I mean that's
excuse me but my point my point
there Dan is a they said no well the
rest is history you know when I open up
I told LeBron and his mom that I hunt
them and Pam and I went over the corner
of this mansion in Malibu and I said you
go to Nike you get yourself a good deal
don't tell them that we screwed up play
play the music with them you know make
them pay whatever it was
so they screwed up I don't know if we
were to sign them but I still believe
Nike would have eventually gone over it
I mean
but I don't know if that's true too this
is still 2 000 what you know one two
three whatever it is right yeah I mean
we're not ready yet LeBron set the next
thing LeBron came in and
overcome what Kobe had done you know by
by that time you know Kobe's great
player and all that stuff he has a
miscue you know he you know he changes
shoe companies all that stuff LeBron was
the next one and LeBron came as closest
to getting what Michael got in his own
shoe but he didn't get it out of it
Adidas screwed up I've known you for a
long time and if you would have said
somebody was going to play you in a
movie I probably wouldn't have picked
Matt Damon I wouldn't have picked
somebody as good looking as Matt Damon
but uh yeah
congratulations yeah well well that is
more than congratulations Matt Damon
playing me you know Dan you you have
known me a long time and I'm so glad we
get to talk to talk about this subject
because you've been with me where times
weren't so good where sometimes you and
a couple other guys gave me a chance to
talk about what it was I was trying to
do you know so to hear you know Matt
Damon I mean my God I mean you know and
Ben and the whole cast I mean these guys
are amazing I mean Ben I mean their
background
I couldn't have picked any I mean who
would I pick I never thought the day
would come this never entered my mind Mr
Patrick ever so
if I should die
tomorrow when we hang up okay I'll know
that I'm at peace with whatever you know
happens and whatever talks about because
I've watched the evolution of something
that very few had a chance to watch the
evolution of a a human being that
actually changed the patterns of America
and that Evolution was Michael Jordan
I'm happy for you sonny and uh you know
continue good health there in Palm
Springs and good luck with the movie
I pray to God I get to see you and your
family one more between we make the last
Rodeo here okay
thank you bun all right God bless you
thank you and Sonny Vaccaro
didn't expect that at the end of the
interview but uh hope he's in
good spirits good health he's in good
hands with his wife Pam but uh Sunny uh
Sunny been around college basketball a
long long long time and I think it
1982 I've known him 40 years and the
highs and lows good and bad from Nike
Adidas Reebok
um and what he did for these college
coaches